think about 80 people in America have
binge eating disorder then
God damn I I do think they're probably
the percentage of people in America
is a lot higher
yeah I'm not saying saying 80 of people
in the in the USA do but I suspect a lot
more people in the USA if you look at
statistics maybe let's look at some
statistics probably a lot more people in
the US do than in the UK
the Obesity um I actually did look this
up so out of the ages of 24 to 25 to 34
23 in the UK are obese 35 are overweight
and 42 percent are normal and I can't
it's so small the underweight category
that I can't even see it so even in the
UK but you can equally have people who
are of a healthy BMI that actually have
a very unhealthy relationship with food
so yes I mean you can you can have a
good BMI and eat bad foods yes yeah yeah
that's possible but it's still a choice
the foods you put in your body are a
choice
for people not eating right like we
can't keep on doing that yeah I don't
think it's excuses but I just I can't I
don't think I can agree how heavily
we're putting it on the fact that it's a
choice but this is but this is what
women do like honestly anytime a man has
a standard we shame them for it and take
accountability away from what no and
this is this is I'm not saying
specifically you right but I'm saying in
general like the men say they want thin
girls or in-shaped girls and then the
body positivity movement comes there's
no but I'm saying there's no there's no
broke man positivity I don't know yeah
because it doesn't exist like we take
away accountability from women's poor
choices and even now like when we're
talking about hey it's a choice if you
eat too much and you gain weight yeah
it's like we're taking accountability
away from the women by saying it's not a
choice
even within the context of bodies right
if I'm I was born six foot so I'm I'm
happy I'm good but you were born sick
sorry genetically
I would genetically pretty supposed to
be six foot cool but if I wasn't if I
was born if I was meant to be five foot
there is no one here that would say to
me women should love you anyway women
should go for you women should find you
attractive they should you might say
that but most women won't so data fat
guy
I have
back where I left
he understand what you're saying you're
like there's some people for example who
might emotionally eat yeah right so we
can we can say we understand why they
made the decisions they did in those
moments right because it may be to cope
with something right right so it's not
saying that we can't have compassion for
why they made those choices but at the
end of the day they did make those
choices yes right and that's what they
are worthy of Love
Tonight
no one is saying that they're not work
no one is saying that they're not worthy
of Love or when they're certain
privilege is that maybe a thinner woman
would be well here's the thing I I when
it comes to thin privilege I think it
actually comes down to
beauty or attractive privilege because
chances are most people will probably
find you more attractive if you're on
the Slimmer side than if you're obese so
you think it's a thing of attractiveness
and pretty privileged not not
necessarily well being being thin or
being being thin or being slim is a
contributing factor to how attractive
some people find you that's just the way
it is so who okay do you know what so as
pick a celebrity that you would say a
female celebrity that you would say
you're attracted to that you think good
right if Megan Good was a size 20
tomorrow how big is that I don't know
how big it is
just big we're talking maybe like she's
she's obese she's obese okay she's obese
it's affected every part of her for my
knees has a face everything okay cool
okay would that would that suddenly
change your level of attraction to her
you've just said it's a contributing
factor so of course yeah because it's
not just the looks it's the self-respect
let me ask you a question
right do you think Michael B Jordan is
hot yeah
are you telling me yeah yeah if you
became obese yeah yeah you were still
waiting physically
are you saying your attraction to him
would be the same
so him working hard to be in shape okay
everyone wants to know who you think is
a 10.
Mark will be Jordan's the seven no
dancing Idris is updated I'm not gonna
laugh
ten is a bit
um
so the one who has the highest standards
yeah is the one that's saying if they
were fat they'd still be necessary
thing is the thing is I just think a lot
of times we lie to like to women that
are overweight and say oh you're still
worthy of love right because it's not
it's not that I say like nobody will
love you but the guys that you want
aren't going to be interested in you
because even bigger girls they don't
want to date bigger guys look at lizzo
her voice
no I I think I think let's get them the
best results so you can either say a
lose weight that's probably the best way
right if lizard lost weight she she'd be
cute like a lot of guys would be
interested and you'll say she's not cute
no not not I mean smash or past lizzo
guys one two three yeah okay now now
guys guys if she was 120 pounds smash or
past lizzo one two three
she would be more attractive yeah yeah
like I'm saying more guys would be
interested I'm not saying everyone but
even but like but like she she could
possibly get the results that she wants
right right or we could lie to her and
say you're beautiful at any size guys
will still be interested but maybe some
but why would you say your issue lies
because it sounds like your issue lies
in okay cool if you're gonna be fat fine
but it's like know it own it and be okay
with the limitations so I have a couple
issues with it I have won the issue that
we lie to women okay so I don't I don't
like telling girls things that aren't
true right so saying like guys will
still love you at any size it's not true
that's not true
okay okay the guys the guys that you
don't want will want you so you could a
guy any guy that gets a lot of money has
a pretty model on his side
or maybe maybe she might not be a model
but she's in she's attractive right you
don't see any billionaires with obese
whale wives so that's that's
statements it's not because because a
lot of times but we're talking about
exceptions and not the rule right you
might find a one-off and usually with
the if the rich guy does have a bigger a
bigger goal with him she got him young
and she gave him that loyalty young and
maybe she gained weight later that's so
unfortunate awesome we're talking about
observable reality we're not just you
know making blacks we're talking about
observable reality we're not saying that
women who are bigger cannot find love
you can however as a result of the fact
that you're fat you're bigger your pool
of men is become smaller unfortunate
you're not denying that but where I have
an issue I'm really not denying that but
where I have an issue is pushing any
narrative that makes it seem like
they're not deserving of the man that
they almost know but they aren't but
they aren't you are deserving it just do
the work together no no I'm saying
you're not deserving if you're obese you
don't deserve a guy that makes six
figures if you you're obese why because
they know because they don't want you
why are we entitled to a man's time
affection and money because I'm big
I'm saying no guys guys let me so what
I'm saying is that you as you were not
entitled nobody's entitled to love you
like so I'm not gonna go to a broke guy
and say oh you're you deserve love I'm
gonna say no get a job
and and so on with the girls I'm not
going to say oh you deserve love I'm
gonna say look I'm sorry if you want
those guys get on the treadmill like
correlate it's it's very similar because
men and women are valued for different
things yeah and so I wouldn't say
unfortunately because it's a lot easier
for a girl to just be thin and pretty
but it's easier and get a banging body
that if he has money and money is very
important money is money I would say
it's much harder to get money than to
stay in shape yep absolutely 100 so if a
guy if a guy wants to make 120 pounds
right a year I think that's a much
harder than losing 50 pounds yeah okay
and so what what I don't like is lying
to women and we coddle them from bad
decisions and we take all the
accountability off of them and keep
allowing them to make bad decisions
instead of instead of telling them the
truth and saying hey if you want this
guy this is the way you can get it
but it's not a lie to tell a bigger
woman that she's beautiful
but here's here's the thing it is
because most of society doesn't see her
as beautiful
and so you could say oh F beauty
standards but we know they exist you you
know who's your prettiest friend you you
guys know you guys know deep down when
you walk into a room you you know
no I'm saying like that's true yeah and
so you you know who it is but that
doesn't mean that the bigger girls are
not beautiful can I ask you a question
okay what is beauty someone someone can
find them beautiful I think all we're
saying is that it's it's
in the observable reality it shows to be
a minority of people but Pearl's not
saying that she's I if I'm wrong correct
me I really feel like she's saying oh no
no no honey you're not deserved but the
thing is no one deserves no one deserves
you
that's true
especially in the dating Marketplace you
get what you deserve right so if you are
not so if there is some if there's
somebody if you are wanting if a man is
wanting a certain kind of woman and he
is not attracting her then he probably
hasn't done the work and done the things
where he deserves that woman because if
he did okay she would come to him and
it's the same for a woman as well I
think I'm struggling with the word
deserve because I just got to say it
guys okay
who is deserving of Love is every single
human being just for being born innately
I feel like innately Hitler and that's
what yeah I think I think I think okay
okay
I don't disagree with you I don't
disagree with you right let's change it
instead of saying love let's say be
chosen no no I mean love I mean love
okay love is love is very broad right I
think nobody is entitled to be chosen by
anyone else in the world I'm not
entirely to be chosen you're not
entitled to be chosen but I have an
entitlement in this world as a human
being to be loved yeah
but what if you're not what if you're
not lovable
no I'm serious that's not true some
people are shitty people immensely and
they're working maybe at least I'm
saying as as a child sure I think every
child deserves to be loved but some
adults are shitty people oh 100 and so a
child don't deserve love a bigger a
bigger child I would actually talk to
the parent because I think it's child
abuse if you're making a person yeah no
no I'm serious because that's the most
that's the biggest disadvantage you can
put your kid at and you're in charge of
their food so if you have an
eight-year-old that's obese I'm talking
to the parents
I'm just gonna say yeah so
um I think the main issue we have here
is
um
what we see over and over again is
people who are obese fat out of shape
trying to shame men into one thing in in
into into into liking them and that's
the main problem so so let's say if I
was with someone right now maybe I mean
we're not dating like I just met her
right just on the larger side I wouldn't
be trying to put her down or anything
right I wouldn't have have an issue like
announce of any issue with her right but
where I might start to develop issues is
when maybe when she starts to tell me
like I should love her for who she is
like like it's like as a person you'll
find your you know you're friendly you
know all that stuff but just on the on
an attraction level it's just not there
but now when you start to try and shame
me to wanting you like to one into being
attracted to you that's just not gonna
work
as a man yeah I feel like for you not
it's just childish you know childish
attraction attraction is not a choice
right it's it's you are you can't
negotiate it what you're attracted to
and who you attract so you wouldn't date
a woman solely because I don't even
saying
I would say yes but on the flip side on
the flip side if you went to a man and
he wasn't making the money that you
wanted him to make you want to give him
the time of day if his personality banks
no you wouldn't give him a chance
this is what you would do this is what
you would do you would date him and hope
he he gets a job but at some point if he
doesn't get a job or start making the
money you want him to make you're gone
okay you're only gonna you're only gonna
put up with that for so long is that
true is that true is that is that true
yes or no are you going to date are you
gonna are you gonna marry a bomb the
rest of your life I don't know yeah yeah
exactly okay hold on guys yes it's two
different things when it comes to
um the size of a woman and uh well how
much money a man make but that's that's
what men value is how a woman looks and
women value how much a man makes because
it's innateness for a man for someone to
be able to provide for us at the end of
the day matter how much money we have
and so it's a harsh reality to
understand like men look at looks they
don't care how much money we have they
don't care where we are at in the totem
pole with finances but they want to be
able to look at us and be like they're
presentable and as women we want to be
able to look at our man and be like
maybe yeah we're attracted to him but
does he have the money does he have the
coins that we need if anything happens
he can provide for me and our family
also on top of that sorry on top of that
you know you you mentioned that um you
know would you so would you um not date
a woman solely on the fact that she's
she's bigger
the thing is I'm not saying that no man
should date a woman that's big if he
wants a data he should however for me
personally I would not date a woman
that's big because it's not conducive
for the sort of relationship I want
because inherently if you are bigger
that means there are certain things you
haven't done you know it means
unfortunately it means you haven't
worked out in a gym it means you haven't
watched what as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible